now rail passengers face further travel
disruption today as staff go on strike
for a third time this week because of a
dispute over pay and job security
joining me now is the general secretary
of the rmt union mick lynch mr good
morning to you thank you so much for
talking to us so where are we with these
talks
well we're constantly engaged with the
companies we've had sessions of
discussions with them all week
we haven't made the advances that we'd
like to make but we will still keep
engaging with them they're putting their
ideas to us
they are along the lines that we've been
telling people that they want to make
very severe changes to our members terms
and conditions they do want to cut
thousands of jobs they want to
re-contract virtually everyone that
works on the railway on a set of terms
and additions and pay that is lower
than we currently have and that in some
ways is a form of fire and rehire
they're saying we either have to adapt
and adopt these new practices
or we will lose our jobs in the greater
numbers
than we even we thought so there is
still that constant threat to us
of mass job losses thousands of jobs
new contracts of employment new working
practices which will be detrimental to
our people
and we still haven't got any offer
that's suitable on pay
and most of our people haven't had a pay
rise for two or three years
because we've spoken to the network rail
and they have said that we had talks
again this morning this was yesterday
we're really getting now into the
nitty-gritty of the reforms we want to
see and how much money that that can
unlock to convert into a better pay deal
on the table so we are making progress
it is inch by inch though rather than
foot by foot so do you agree with brie
with that there is progress being made
in these talks
well we are getting to down to what they
actually want they're giving us a lot of
detail about what they want from
what they might call the new modern
railway what we don't know is how our
members going to respond to that we hear
a lot of
a lot of the changes they want to make
but our members when they hear it will
find a lot of these changes very
difficult
to take on board so we'll have to see
what the complete package is and then
we'll have to go to our people
and consult them in detail to see if
they want to accept this package
so there's a long way to go yet
but most of the stuff that our members
voted
very heavily in favor and for action
about
are what's on the table now and they've
not diluted
very much the stuff that they want and
that's true of the train operators and
network rail and we have to make sure
that we keep both of these things moving
together we don't want one of the one
section of the railway in advance of the
other and we are determined to get a
settlement for all 43 000 people in this
dispute
so where we are today this morning do
you think we're going to have more
strikes
well at the moment we will have strikes
because we've we've got
have not got an offer on the three
elements of the deal we've got
job security which means uh thousands of
job cuts and that's still on the table
we've got these working practices and
conditions which as i've said are very
difficult to absorb and we haven't got a
pay deal and we've now got another
element
uh on the mainline railway in the train
operating companies about pension cuts
and pension reforms and we've also got
that issue on london underground so it's
likely
unless we get a lot of movement
provided by the government that the
companies can change their stance that
there will be more action yes and we've
got a funding crisis at the bottom of
this
all of these disputes are about a two
billion pound cup on the mainline
railway and a two billion pound cut on
transport for london and that is what's
difficult to swallow because if you cut
that amount of money out of the system
the worker's going to be worse off and
that's what the situation we're facing
and we've got to deal with that and so
it's a tough set of negotiations to go
i'm sorry if talks are happening and
even if there is progress only inch by
inch and everyone's saying there is some
progress being made then why strike why
disrupt
the entire nation with this
well we haven't named any strike action
at the moment this is the strike action
we
call to get the companies to the table
but what you've got to remember what
they're calling progress is them taking
money off our members to a large extent
any pay offer
that they make to us which is only in
the region of three percent at the
moment and inflation is rampant in
double figures at the moment will be
funded by
job losses and changes to working
practices and to a large extent
re-contracting staff on lower wages
so it's not as if we're getting loads of
money off these companies they're
actually offering lower money
uh into the system and taking money out
of the system rather than putting money
into it usually when you go into pay
talks you're looking for new money to
come on the table and that's not the
case at the moment so it's going to be
very difficult for us to get a
settlement and if they do what they said
last week that they're actually going to
start making the redundancies
that will harden our position and if
they threaten our members jobs we will
take more action
again back to what network rail said
they said that they
they need to have a modern railway um
modernizing it and modernizing
maintenance means that the workforce
will shrink but that they believe they
can make most of the changes without
forcing anyone out of a job
well they can make changes for 12 years
network rail gave us a guarantee of no
compulsory redundancies they withdrew
that
last year in preparation for this
dispute because they were getting ready
for it what we need them to do is commit
to no compulsory redundancies and then
we can
discuss with them this modern railway
which we are already doing
and the flexibilities they're looking
for but that can't completely disrupt
our members lives and their work-life
balance we want our members to be able
to see their families and live in their
communities what they're offering at the
moment is almost constant nights and
constant weekend working at night
and that will change our members lives
and they simply don't get rewarded at
level they're not night workers the pay
and the salaries is very modest and what
they want in return for the check what
they're giving in return for the changes
they're proposing is not adequate
and i'm not convinced at the moment that
our members will accept that so we've
got to be very cautious
about what they call progress there may
be progress in their agenda but it
doesn't mean that our members going to
accept those changes just because the
company wants them so we've got to work
that problem through with them we will
do that as constructive
uh
in a constructive dialogue but it's
still a long way to go
if you don't think
if you don't think your members are
going to accept
what they've got on the table it sounds
like you do think there are going to be
more strikes
throughout this summer i mean do you
have days
that you are looking to have more action
when do you think that would be we have
we have not selected any days but the
whole point of a dialogue in a
negotiation is that people change their
position
and you get to a new position that
doesn't belong to either party
so that you can form a constructive way
forward now at the moment
the companies have given us all the
reforms they want but they're not
listening
fully to what we need and what our
members need to get a decent
working life
on the railway and that's got to change
they need to change their position
in terms of what they're offering in
terms of pay what they can do for job
security and the way that they engage
their staff
and come to agreement with us about the
way people work so we'll work with with
them on that we've not named dates we're
going to
review where we are in the discussions
next week and then we will decide
if we need to take more action
so that decision will come next week on
whether or not you're going to take more
action well i haven't said that what i
said is we'll review where we are next
week we'll see where the discussions are
going we'll allow time for more
discussions and then we'll decide what
we're going to do when we've consulted
our members so no strikes until then
say that again no more strikes until
then
well we have to give two weeks notice of
strikes anyway that's the legislation so
there won't be any strikes in the in you
know in the next couple of weeks but
we'll decide that but we won't hesitate
to use more industrial action if we
can't reach an agreement or if the
companies carry through their threats to
make people redundant network rail
issued a notice a formal letter of
redundancy
last week that's entirely unacceptable
as a step to take in the middle of a
negotiation that we won't take those
threats
lightly so we need to get on with
constructive dialogue and that's the
best way to avoid more industrial action
by reaching a settlement that's
that suits both parties needs
okay mr lynch thank you so much for your
time this morning